hello welcome back to three scary games
I'm glad you could join us
can you hear it can you hear it calling
to you it's coming closer and closer to
you and soon it will find you nobody
finds you it won't serve you do a very
special welcome to siren head Oh little
laggy that's okay I don't know if I was
supposed to turn around and immediately
go backwards I don't know why that's my
first instinct for games but I'm going
backwards sorry if this games running a
little jittery there were no quality
options and I looked for them so as you
may have noticed there are siren had
good games that are coming out I kind of
called that one I knew it was going to
happen and this one seems to be in the
vein of the old maybe I shouldn't have
turned around and gone that way maybe I
should have gone some other way maybe I
should have gone forward the way that it
wanted me to do it maybe should have
assumed as soon as I heard a siren that
it was gonna be bad news for me
haha great so I don't know what just
continue our casual conversation - siren
ed breeze down my neck I'm hoping that I
don't need to find papers I don't think
that much like Slenderman or not like
Slenderman I don't think siren ed is a
doodler I don't think siren ed doodles
much
[Music]
I see in it what's in it
where's oh oh there it is Oh what
happens if I go under the woods what
happens if I don't run into a drink hey
buddy I can't go in the woods the woods
are barred so what would one do about
this situation seems like maybe at both
ends of this trail that I decided to go
hiking on there seems to be siren hoods
seems to be multiples mult multi multi
bit mold mold multiple multi men there's
multiple men I'm assuming these are
siren men it might be siren women
they're huge
siren dicks flopping in the wind not the
women maybe the women I don't know so
I'm gonna go back now and I'm gonna
guess that it's still gonna be there I
can't see a thing it's so dark I know
it's there where oh that's yeah it's
like barely I see it barely all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna see what's up
[Music]
it ate me maybe I could go around it
it's not very fast but it was a wide
circle of which it could touch me
because it's got long arms its arms are
long as hell super with long fingers and
a long dick I don't know what I'm
supposed to do what am I supposed to do
is that a pile of logs no it's a tent Oh
oh [ __ ] look out there's a siren heard
there's a big move okay maybe I can I
can't sprint exactly ah okay so I don't
know if there's a main objective besides
just go in the woods and try not to die
from yield siren head because if there
is I'm not a hundred percent sure what
to do about it
oh there you are okay it is creepy I got
it mask creepy it's gotta be a way to
get around but the woods are all blocked
off are you doing you crying little
[ __ ] baby crying you stuck you can't
make it any farther can't make it
further I get it maybe I can move maybe
I can oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay so there's gotta be a way that I
can get around him boobity scoop at him
and I think I just got to find a wide
point hope him and scooped him scoop and
poop him I've never thought that I was
gonna have to scoop in Boop a siren head
but here we are I kind of kind of a wide
berth here maybe I could there might be
enough room Hey boobies go be hey what's
up boobie Scooby yeah yeah you're gonna
scoop that poop and I'm gonna scoop the
loop around you
and it's gonna be epic and awesome come
off the trail you know you want to
[Music]
okay I think I know the way oh I got
past it that took way too long oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
hi oh my god my god I don't know what
this is does this have many meaning to
me I just found a house in the woods yes
I found a house in the woods well that's
weird don't know why this is here so so
so so what about that so so what about
that so what about that
is there something incredibly amazing
about the house in the woods some kind
of Blair Witch ass [ __ ] going on up here
that was way too hard to get past those
dudes I'm gonna consider this the end
and I'm gonna consider me having one it
go team go
we did it guys we did it all right I'm
gonna end that one there wait I I
probably should have just stopped way
sooner but I for some reason I just kept
going at it alright what moving on all
right so this is SCP six seven eight
nine now technically siren head is not
an SCP want to be very clear about this
this is not a real SCP designation is
not nothing you are a guy named Mike and
you will live in a small home in a
lovely neighborhood your wife Sam has
been out for two hours and should have
been back a while ago the news on TVs
said to stay in your home so matter the
situation but cut - static before you
could find out why and you can't find
the remote well that's just awful that
situation is terrible you don't want
that at all you don't want none of that
I'm getting worried about Sam I need to
find the remote those are my two
priorities in that order
okay gravity's a little
oh I can't seem to leave my home oh good
I found it I don't I guess let's flip it
over to the news oh sure that's some
news what's that sound what's that out
the window I can't even see a window Oh
hey hey hey
[Music]
it's Sam Oh Sam what the hell was that
nice check out second yeah maybe I
should
I can't even see where am i it's so dark
oh I have a last light now Oh beautiful
stars where did the car go Sam I didn't
see coming
Mike body was found on the sidewalk next
to his home has heard been flattened to
only 2 inches in height and his wife Sam
redacted is believed to be in the car
the ongoing investigation is determined
what could have caused their deaths with
the additional sighting of a very large
and distorted figure roaming the
neighborhood a siren ed short film is in
the planning phase this is part of the
report this is oh that's it fascinating
but only fascinating because what the
hell
I guess that hardly counted is one and
then hardly counted all right so this
this next game probably the most
terrifying of all siren ed games B siren
head dating sim what's my name my name
is mark yes we're doing this everybody
we are doing this and you are a part of
this we are doing this together we're
all in this together
I decided to start my day with a walk in
the woods Wow Alex Ian put on like some
cliche dating sim music going on here
real plunky real you know you know the
type you love yourself a dating sim told
you I know you I know you come on you
you love them you'll you love them too
much but I don't judge it's okay all
right you go enjoy put in the music all
right cool thank you people who use it
often but lately I haven't seen anyone
around is it because of the B he
what a siren sound it's rare to get a
tornado around here suddenly out of
nowhere whoa
huh you fall to the ground siren hey
this is it this is how I die let's see
uh I just wanted ice cream
darn it stops stares at you
siren head lifts you up and gives you a
nice overview of the forest wow this
view is beautiful Ewan siren ed walk off
to an ice-cream store Oh
do you want some ice cream - siren head
[Laughter]
[Music]
you sue me saying yes I would very much
like some ice cream mark
okay let's order some the ice cream man
looks at both of you with the terrified
look what flavor would you like to get I
like me a good old chocolate chocolate
please sorry Ned slowly turns his head
towards you oh you don't know what he's
saying
you think it's somewhere along the lines
of what the [ __ ] you know I'm allergic
to chocolate
you f double O your attic and then siren
it dies fruit chocolate allergy hope
you're happy you monster Wow all right
quick save I forgot about a quick sale
all right god damn it right now can't
end like you try to punch tired and you
miss period explodes you die Oh perfect
I I can get these it's perfect I got
this so I Vernell is good - vanilla
please turn as slowly turns you don't
know what he's saying but you assume
it's I can't believe you're such a basic
[ __ ] - chocolate you [ __ ] up your
dispose and you die
alright strawberry strawberry please
all right you have no idea this my long
lines of I would like strawberry to
please it's hard it puts his ice cream
into his mouth if I had no idea but do
you think it's somewhere along the lines
of please tell me your life story
oh wow on the first date no thanks I
don't really want to oh man time to die
guess I'm dead sure I'll tell you well I
had a really happy childhood except for
one thing was incredibly poor couldn't
have anything when I was young my dog
ran away it never came back
I miss him siren it stays quiet for a
second no no oh good god Sparky you
sound just like him wait a minute does
that mean you killed my dog you bastard
mission abort mission abort the [ __ ]
found out you just had to bring up your
missing dog didn't you books that's
adorable nobody had ever done something
so thoughtful for me Oh feel yourself
start blushing as well on other things
start to blush is this what love feels
like this was a lovely date siren head I
hope we can hang out again soon Wow
uh-huh you have no idea what he just
said but you think it's somewhere along
the lines of I love you I love you too
siren it I love you too
[Music]
okay anyway sorry oh man too much PDA
Wow
Wow they'll slice something special as
scary as gave anyone's ever experience
ever that's great that's great okay so
this is a different take of siren head
this is a 2d platformer style ooh
interesting
oh I don't know what I am and a horrible
bug creature
yeah he's normal just gonna go through
John Norwood this reminds me of like
Newgrounds horror games like old flash
games yeah it's totally fine definitely
nothing gonna jump out of me at any
moment all good in this neighborhood oh
that's not good
[Music]
okay
Oh
[Music]
hey buddy hidin oh hey I'll see you
around
Oh sit around all right guess I'll go
home then I guess today is not the day
to go into the woods should have stopped
at the dead body and maybe thought the
hey uh maybe I'll head home
maybe I'll maybe I'll go home
[Applause]
oh so this is another game that is
unsurprisingly called siren ed helped
drag your cursor to look around only one
camera may function at a time if click
the repair button turn tape stable
please note sign it as and now will not
move on certain tapes that are playing
Oh what
wait so is this is this like a five
nights at freddys style
siren head game chambers like maybe
there's a bit of a problem with that oh
great
oh I can go outside
what what what am i doing why worry
about going outside Oh drive
I think this is a lesson of what I've
been trying to say about every five
nights at Freddy's game fan game sequel
that I've ever played you get in your
car and you get the [ __ ] out and you go
you go home you kid your car whatever
your job is don't matter if this siren
ed in your cameras you go home all right
I think I think I'm tapping out I think
what what is interesting here is there's
a lot of people that are trying to make
siren head games and they're pumping
them out it's it's interesting because
there's a lot of people that are trying
which I haven't seen a lot of people
make games about a certain subject in a
long time and there's varying levels of
quality but that being said like as
short as some of these experiences are
like that was like a minute on some of
those it's interesting it is interesting
so I went I think that's all for now I
there anymore siren head games out there
yet however not bad so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below there are other siren ed
games that I've somehow missed link them
down there thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
bye-bye
[Music]